jean du drame aujourd'hui quasiment rien
n'a changé la population est encore
victime de nombreuses séquelles médicale
elle vit dans une extrême pauvreté et
aucun responsable de l' usine n'a été
condamné philippe castel philippe
hernando les sirènes l'ont même pas
retenté cette nuit là elle avait été
débranché pour ne pas affoler la
population
il est mieux à bhopal le gaz mortel ce
récent en trois jours on dénombrera
entre sept et dix mille morts
au final vingt mille personnes ont perdu
la vie ici
quand j'ai entendu le gars s'est échappé
alors j'ai couru vers l'hôpital est un
combat physique et morale et cela fait
20 ans que la catastrophe tu dans les
bidonvilles de bhopal on estime à 600
mille le nombre de personnes qui ont été
affectées problèmes respiratoires
malformations cancer tuberculose au
coeur d'une population défavorisée cent
mille roupies pour mon mari à l'hôpital
mais on ne pourra pas le sauver aucune
médecine ne pourra l'aider à mieux
respirer
il est condamné toutes les conséquences
surgissent maintenant les gens n'ont pas
d'argent parce qu'ils tombent
constamment malade et ne sont pas
capables de travailler vingt mille morts
600 plaintes
lezoka responsable pas ma main prochain
l'entreprise américaine union carbide a
été racheté par doté mickeal le patron
de l'époque règne anderson avait été
interpellé pour homicide
puis libéré sous caution il ne s'est
jamais présenté à la justice indienne
il ya eu un accord
en 1989 la compagnie américaine union
carbide a accepté de payer une somme de
470 millions $ pour solde de votre
compte
elle n'a jamais permis que ses
dirigeants viennent en inde pour
répondre de leurs actes devant la
justice qu'il soit même interrogé par la
justice indienne et c'est aussi un
élément de ce déni de justice que nous
déboursons vingt ans plus tard le site
ne veut pas n'a même pas été dépollués
comme si tout le monde avait décidé
d'oublier